Another question I got was, what do Republicans
do if Donald Trump runs in 2024 based on the
numbers right now with Trump leading a 20
24 primary poll, Republicans do nothing.
This as a.
Right now, this is Donald Trump's for the
taking now, of course, depending on what happens
in 2022 and depending on what happens with
polling around Trump versus non Trump Republicans
beyond 2020, two things could change.
But right now, Donald Trump.
In a recent poll of 20 24 primary voters,
Trump has 53 percent support.
Second place is pense with 12 percent support.
Third place is Don Junior with I think it
was somewhere around six percent support.
So this is a difficult position to be in if
you are a non Trump Republican, because based
on the math right now, the twenty twenty four
nomination is Trump's.
If he wants it, he will be 78 years old.
At the time.
It's unclear what criminal or civil issues
he will have in the state of Georgia, in the
state of New York, who knows?
Four years is a very, very long time.
But what do Republicans do if Trump runs in
2024?
As of right now, it doesn't seem there's anything
they can do other than saying we're taking
our ball and going home.
Meaning, fine, if it's going to be Trump in
the Republican Party, we'll start a third
party.
And that's what some former Republican officials
have been saying.
But the twenty twenty four field, I think
we're getting ahead of ourselves.
But the 2024 field likely is going to wait
to see if Trump makes an announcement about
running other than overtly anti Trump.
Republicans like if Mitt Romney were to run
for the nomination in 2024, I don't think
he will.
I think Romney's past it.
But if Romney were Romney's been an anti Trump
Republican for a long time, I think he would
just do it.
But people like Lindsey Graham, Chris Christie,
I don't know, because he was against Trump
than he was with them than I was.
It seems to be against them.
The people who are sort of aligned with Trump
are going to wait and take a lead from Trump.
Right now, the Republican base is Donald Trump's
base.
This is just a reality.
Something like.
Eighty five percent of Republicans want Trump
to stay involved in politics, 64 percent of
Republicans.
If Trump left and said, follow me to my new
party, would go with him.
And right now, you have a situation where
the Republican base is Donald Trump's base
that could change.
Moderates are in this position where.
I'm using the term moderate's carefully, by
the way, so-called moderate Republicans are
in a position where they don't really know
whether 20 22 will be a reinforcement of the
Trumpy and wing or a rebuke of the Trumpy
and wing.
And if indeed the champions win again in twenty
twenty two, and if indeed Donald Trump chooses
to run in 2024, you may see the so-called
moderates split from the party and that could
have delightfully disastrous consequences
for the Republican Party.
We'll see.
I think the focus for now should be a starting
to think about 20 22